I think garage saleing there's the big
ROI play because the garage sale eBay
conversion has some of the biggest
margins in the world what are we asking
for these days I don't even know Vanessa
Russ I truly believe that it that every
person can make a thousand dollars a
week by waking up at 5 o'clock in the
morning garage saling on a Saturday for
four hours and then posting this stuff
they find on eBay
have any video games what do you think
air looks the best city can you do
in Pilatus Porter was
I like it that's a serious thing I think
it actually is because a lot of people
like how do I make money like it's right
they are like literally become educated
on VHS and DVD and CD like arbitrage of
a because everybody's selling them at
garage sales like three bucks for a box
of them and you'll make a thousand
dollars every weekend this is gonna be
the charm box you know 40 to 200 boys
and girls all the pieces are 150 they
make a hundred fifty bucks in ten
seconds at 7:30 in the morning set we
have to we have to quote excuse why do
you [ __ ] that'll make everything direct
you're working at a squirrel it's very
who wants a thousand dollars every week
very practical person all right
I like practicality